i accept this nomination for president
of the united states of america 32 years
after he first ran for president joe
biden
is now the democratic candidate the last
man standing in what was a large field
but while i'll be a democratic candidate
i will be an american president
and now he will face donald trump in
november a man he's previously described
as out of his depth incompetent and
racist
but a man he criticized without ever
using his name in his speech
the choice could not be more clear
no rhetoric is needed just judge this
president on the facts
five million americans infected by covet
19.
more than 170 000 americans have died
by far the worst performance of any
nation on earth
more than 50 million people have filed
for unemployment this year
the acceptance was moved to an arena in
his home state of delaware it was
delivered to an empty room
with family watching backstage a nearby
stadium was converted into a drive-in
theater
to allow people to watch the speech on a
big screen
from the socially distant safety of
their cars
and the democratic challenger told the
country he knows
being the guy who is not donald trump
isn't enough to win
as president the first step i will take
we to get control of the virus that has
ruined so many lives
will we be the generation that finally
wipes out the stain of racism
from our national character i believe
we're up to it
i believe we're ready and he promised a
different foreign policy
in a biden white house i'll be a
president who will stand
with our allies and friends and make it
clear to our adversaries
the days of cozying up to dictators is
over
the final speech at a convention is
normally marked with huge cheers and
traditionally a balloon drop
this was a different ending for what has
been a different kind of convention
so joe biden has finally convinced the
democratic party he should be
the presidential candidate normally
after the convention the candidate hits
the campaign trail criss crossing the
country but because of covid
that can't happen this time round but
still
he has 11 weeks to convince the country
that what he put on display in his
speech
his vision his policies even his
personality
is what america needs now alan fisher al
jazeera
wilmington delaware